please to have on this show for the
first time on the phone always enjoy
seeing him face to face when he comes
here cuz you just love him he just comes
in all badass leather boots smoking
heaters out there and our thoroughfare
he's crushing it they bring the baseball
bat I think he brought Lucille but he'd
grabbed our one of our bats and started
wheeling around like he's I'm like he's
negan as he plays on on The Walking Dead
the season 10 finale he's gonna lay heir
later this year delayed due to a Cove at
19 and for the moment though as he is
hanging in there's now a show Friday
night in with the Morgans hosted by
Jeffrey Dean Morgan and his wife Hilary
Burton Morgan and that's on AMC starting
tomorrow night at 10:00 Eastern Time and
back here on the shows Jeffrey Dean
Morgan how are you sir very good where I
found you I know I'm following you on
Twitter I'm seeing you driving around
you know and uh you know nearby I guess
in the woods or something on drunk
driving around in the woods a lot well
we've got a farm up here okay State New
York right
so yeah I'm I'm actually very lucky to
have this farm especially right now
because my lockdown consists of quite a
bit of land so I can just kind of doubt
myself out no one's killing each other
it's going okay okay well that's good
that's good I mean everybody's healthy
in your world everybody there my roof so
far so good but we have we have really
adhered to the not leaving the most I'll
do is I delivered my wife has been
making masks for local hospitals and
caregivers here in the Hudson Valley and
so I will pack up a box of mass that she
makes and deliver those to the frontline
workers but even then it's kind of a you
know dine and dash situation I'll throw
a box out of a moving car bet I hear
what you're saying so did the masks of
any specific design on them or they
I mean mine as she made one for me
that's you know Seahawk mask but she's
making them out of started with old
shopping bags because they're made out
of material that is basically a filter
and 95 filter so that's what it started
as and then and then we've gotten more
materials found them online and and so
yeah she's she's churning those up the
sewing machine has been going 12 hours a
day for the last three weeks and I
figured out how to make hand sanitizer
so we're doing what we can how do you
how does one make hand sanitizer you can
have like rubbing alcohol is your main
ingredient right so glycerin a little
hydrogen peroxide you can put a little
tea tree oil in there if you want to
smell like something other than alcohol
are you using it are you using any of
your knowledge of survivalism from from
Waukee for involve I wish I you know
bashed the hell out of the virus but in
my family you know you just can't see
the damn thing I think in this situation
for those familiar with the show there
was a character at one time named
Hershel who lived on a farm and had
isolated his family on this farm and
that's very much kind of the character I
have I've kind of simulated my life
after at this point so yeah we just
locked down at the farm man it really is
this and now and now we're gonna try
this show and we'll see what happens
there and of the Friday night in with
the Morgans and no right so let me just
put a pin in that for a second we'll
return to it after let's go down a
little bit of a Seahawk wormhole sir
let's let's go down that it I mean if I
had told you at the beginning of last
season that Marshawn Lynch would return
and and then be part of a playoff run
your answer would have been what no
there's no way not I I mean I knew that
we would be in the thick of things for a
playoff spot but to bring Marshawn back
the seals number 24 beats mode come back
oh yeah I was I bought all that merch
I'm gonna you know section it was
announced I was on the beastmode website
buying everything that I could I was
pretty exciting and you know what he
looked okay he looked pretty good to me
well yeah I mean certainly for a guy
that I'm imagining there had to be some
sort of a run-up right that that that
that that he knew it was potentially in
the offing but I mean that's what the
rumor is you know they've been talking
about this for a little while they've
been talking about it even before he
went down with injury Marshawn had had
been at the Seattle offices and said hi
to everybody and I think talk started
then just for him to kind of back up
Carson and then when everybody got hurt
it was that was it yeah it was a farmer
and then you know that last game of the
year against the Niners to come you know
what 1/4 inch from winning the division
Oh
Walker it's what can I say free the
crazy thing and we've talked about her
on this show ad nauseam might as well
just bring it up here I mean that
quarter inch that was on Sunday Night
Football the finale game 256 of the
regular season
had that been you know a quarter inch in
the other direction you know as San
Francisco would have been on the road to
start the playoffs as the five seed the
Saints would have gotten to by the
Packers would have gotten the 1 seed and
the Seahawks would have gotten a home
game the following weekend I mean that I
mean that's what you want to talk about
normally baseball is a game of inches
that was a game of quarter inch right
there was you know I've relived these
moments quite a bit in my mind mindless
things also and will just pop up in her
and that's the new one for me at that
moment yeah that would have changed the
whole NFC's playoff it's your first or
and and you know Seattle
home you can't bet against him at home
ever Russell Wilson is something to
behold and how he consistently pulls off
these games I mean last year I I don't
know how many come back yet I should
know that but you know fourth-quarter
comebacks I want him with the ball in
the fourth quarter with the minute on
the clock and I feel like we're gonna
win every time it was a remarkable
number of one-possession wins for the
seahawks this year for sure Jeffrey Dean
Morgan here on the Rich Eisen show who
do you want your Seahawks to draft if
they could - they're sitting there 27th
overall got a couple of - knows what do
you think this team needs what do you
think this team needs well i guy i guess
i am a CEO guy but i'm in the draft room
you know I've been saying this for the
last you know seven years we need
offensive life but you know I think we
also need to shore up the edge and if we
can't figure out what to do with
clowning and I'm really hoping that we
get him back but I think we need help on
the edge you're not and we've got to
protect Russell you know we every year
it's kind of the same story with us a
draft time and then you know as as we do
every year we'll turn I think we've got
seven picks this year right now and I'm
sure that's gonna turn into 11 or 12
yeah all right but this year's a lot
different you know no one's getting to
meet these players
no one's getting to see them work out so
you're really having to just look at
film which I like I think that's a good
way to go about it but you know
Seattle's big on character Pete has
these guys that he likes and it's a very
certain kind of a mindset and so I
imagine there's a lot of skyping going
on right now um but I'd like to see I'd
like to see offensive line and and I
think there's a couple places where you
go in the defense but I think that Pete
and Paul will probably end up getting a
receiver they like the receiver they
like quarterbacks those they always seem
to kind of come out of nowhere and draft
so really it's sort of a guessing game
with the COS and we'll see if we end up
that 27th pick I just don't do they
never do they always seem to trade that
one out your Seahawks fans sit around
for 2-3 hours they're like okay finally
here we go we're ready to eat and then
all of a sudden it turns in his second
round or in two threes and a five and a
six and whatever but hey it works out I
mean your point where you know which
Schneider and and with Pete they know
their system they know the hole always
complete always compete mantra and
finding the right guys and DK Metcalf
was remarkable last year I mean what a
story I mean you know we thought what he
did in the combine but you never know
how that's going to translate on Sunday
right hand Wow
well it's so fun to see him and lock it
you know playing together and kind of
figuring out how they're gonna play and
and he really was a beast and and kind
of carried us the wide receivers thought
well you know Lockett was hurt for the
better part of the second half of the
year right really stepped up fun to
watch and I can't wait to see him go
some more
I think this year he's it's possible
he's really gonna have a breakout year
is my prediction alright yeah I'm
knocking on wood on that and that's
obviously we're all hoping for for the
best on that front and in the meantime
you know you're helping provide people
with what we're doing right now and
that's a little bit of a diversion
tell me about Friday night in with the
Morgans you and your wife just gonna
just shoot it for just like an hour and
just see what's going on and one hour
right now I mean that could change right
now it's a half hour and you know I was
just I was actually doing a hospital run
I was in my car listening to you know
Howard Stern as I did your how it's
always talk radio in my car when I'm
driving and they were talking about the
technology and trying to put a zoom show
together and I had just done an episode
of the talking debt which is a follow up
of walking on Sundays they do and we had
done a Skype version of that show and I
thought it had gone relatively okay
considering it was the first time many
of us had done it and I emailed Sara
Burnett the head of AMC and I said hey
what do you think about us doing a show
with this new format and just chatting
with some friends I'm bringing in some
actor friends and and then we bring in
someone from our community that this
community we're in is a very tight-knit
small community and everybody's been so
helpful kind of during this time of
craziness
and so we have brought on so far we
brought in a doctor for our first
episode our family doctor who can serve
a lot of questions that we all had about
about this virus and next week we're
gonna bring on our local agriculture
guru who has helped me and teach me how
to run farm essentially hmm and he's
going to talk to us about what's going
on in that world because that's that's
as effective as everything else with
this and everybody's running out and
buying chickens and stuff now thinking
they're gonna or gardening and thinking
they're gonna you know with it were
gonna be in this pandemic to lock down
forever and so we're gonna ask him some
questions about that so it's just a
really kind of odd mix of people that
are mostly out there doing really good
things for the community and just you
know it tone is so important as you know
how can you have fun when such horrible
crap is going on in the world and I
think finding that the right tone is is
going to be very important for us and
one that I'm keenly aware of because
it's a lot and but we're hoping we can
bring a smile to some people's faces and
and might even get a little bit of
knowledge out of that we'll see I mean
it's really flying by the seat of our
pants be honest with them and and I'm
and I look forward to to seeing some of
that and I imagine you can combine
celebrity actor friends and and also
folks from around the communities that
mean rudd we're gonna see a Paul Rudd
yeah of course it means but right now we
are
to do four episodes and of course rug
responded to my email slower than
everyone else respond to the emails cool
long time is when he's at the super
bowl-winning yes dude in my life as did
during that yeah right now we're doing
four episode if we do more he's in five
believe it or not I imagine we'll
probably do more than more the way
things are going yeah I look forward to
seeing him again it debuts on Friday
April 17 to 10 Eastern Time before I let
you go we had a fan call in in our first
hour on our YouTube stream youtube.com
slash Rich Eisen show big fan of your
show wondering how negan in the middle
of the zombie apocalypse gets to keep
his hair so pristine and perfect answer
for this fan is there is there a zombie
hairdresser or barber that negan goes to
sort of my guess on this but he does
seem to have a nice haircut week in and
week out and here's how crazy I am is I
decided to see if I could kind of give
myself up fade the negan fades using a
nice and so believe it or not Wow
I cut my hair for that Joe using the
night what what are you serious yeah
yeah yeah I had to try it I had to make
sure that and I'm not a method guy I'm
like you know don't use a hairdresser
but but I knew I knew that I get asked
about it for years I've been welcomed no
one's bugging negan about his gelled up
hair with his nice haircut and when I
was in jail the season I was in jail I
decided to see if I could cut my hair
using a really sharp knife and and you
can I'm glad that you've lived to tell
the tale I'm glad I imagine so but I did
not expect an answer like that I'm glad
to have gotten at least the positive
result you're the first one that's
actually asked it again
you know what again I give credit to to
Rich Eisen show viewer I give all the
credit right there how are you in the
family have great Susie and I are doing
fine we've got an 11 9 and six-year-old
at home they're healthy thank goodness
and there have been there have been
challenges on keeping everybody you know
just uh sane but it's all good we're
healthy and and and thrilled that we are
able to do this show we're doing social
distancing on this program by being here
so we're knocking on wood yes sir let's
stitch you're the great the charity
you're normally sitting in is empty so
we yeah man love to have you back here
love to have you back here you take care
of yourself Jeffrey okay alright you too
and say hi to everybody there everybody
there and hopefully we'll see you soon
you got it right back at you that's
Jeffrey Dean Morgan be good Jeff if you
will the worse half of the new show
Friday night in with the Morgans that's
debuting tomorrow night at 10:00 Eastern
on AMC hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here